sukuna is hisoka on steroids
just like probably the most iconic
character in hunter hunter the king of
curses is
love for his charisma is purely driven
by his sadistic hedonism
and serves as a complete wild card in
the story helping both the heroes
and the villains just as often as he
likes to hurt or straight out
ignore them always looking for a way to
benefit
himself
and yet despite his cruelty selfishness
and darkness
just like the psychopathic clown the
king of curses is as
popular with fans as most of the
quote-unquote good guys
so what exactly is it that makes sukuna
so
fascinating to watch as i've already
mentioned in previous videos
akutami loves taking popular tropes from
anime and manga
merge them and improve on them and so it
comes as no big
surprise that sukuna emerges as one of
the most rounded
complex and intriguing villains that
i've ever come across
so let's discuss his backgrounds his
role in the story
his relationship to itadori megumi and
gojo and
whether or not he truly is all evil
this is the story of the omen sukuna
introduced in the story as the king of
curses who lived over a thousand years
ago
in the golden age of jujutsu in ancient
japan where he was the most
powerful being alive despite being an
actual human
as akutami clarified in an interview
however he wasn't so much
curse user as natural calamity
apparently however he still remembers
his past life as a human quite well
after his death however he became a
cursed spirit
so powerful that his body could not be
destroyed but had to be divided into
parts and sealed away
my god this man akutami really has a
rich imagination to come up with
something like
and i'm being told that this is actually
all based on real japanese history
so it's time for a short japanese
history lesson
it's time for japanese history
with ryoman
it's history because as it turns out
yomen sukuna is actually a historic
figure
well kind of this person is mentioned in
the second oldest record of japan's
history
the nihon shoki completed in the 8th
century a.d
admittedly though parts of it cross
heavily into mythology and shinto
religion
so it's often really impossible to
separate legend from
facts in this book however that is
filled with myths and politics alike
sukuna is described as a demon-like
person significantly taller than any
human
with two faces two arms and two legs
the apathetiomen by the way literally
meaning two-faced
he's said to have appeared in hida
prefecture today's gifu that you can see
on the map
here see here's tokyo that by the way
didn't exist back then
that that's gifu here i mean i don't
want you finishing this video without
having learned anything right
anyways here sukuna terrorized the
people until a brave military commander
was finally able to expel
him from the land interestingly enough
however while the nihon shoki describes
him as a villain and an enemy of the
emperor
people in hida and mino provinces
treated roman tsukuna as a hero and
benefactor and actually worshiped him
and there is actually a shrine just
dedicated to sukuna that still
exists in gifo prefecture today with a
statue that
doesn't look quite as cool as this
[Music]
bless anime now since there's still very
little that we know about him
i think the best way to understand
sukuna's character is by looking at the
three most defining
relationships so far that each give us a
different perspective on his personality
these relationships are with gojo with
itadore and
megumi who has long been teased to play
a central role in the story as well
now as you might remember from my
analysis of gojo's character
there are a lot of parallels between
these two being the two most
self-centered and individualistic
characters
both were introduced pretty much at the
same time right at the beginning of the
story
one as the strongest sorcerer and one as
the king
of curses and the two of them clearly
share this incredible aura of power
superiority and total control especially
during battle
next to their immense charisma both of
them also value strength
over all else in a way though both are
also
incredibly immature and cruel playing
with other people and
especially sukuna turning every single
fight into some sort of game
now these parallels that akutami clearly
draws between these two characters
strongly suggests that they will face
off again at some point in the story
and yet of course there are also some
striking differences between the two
that i think will help us explain
sukuna's character
a little bit better the most fundamental
difference here is of course that gojo
is a good guy and sukuna is a baddie
but since we're dealing with a lot of
morally grey and actually quite complex
characters here
let's not be quite that superficial the
main moral difference between the two
lies in their approach towards the
central moral question of jujutsu kaisen
what constitutes a good life worth
living
for gojo the answer here is strength
itself
when you're strong you can use that
strength to shape the world as you
please
which in gojo's case means helping those
he cares for
sukuna's approach is actually quite
similar however for him
a life worth living is the most extreme
form of hedonism
as he uses his power to satisfy any of
his desires
which often include the mental or
physical tormentation of others
now in this context gojo's
self-confidence
always using his strength for the sake
of others and trying to make a better
world as he sees fit
are all good things but the fact that he
believes that no matter how strong he
becomes
no matter how hard he fights he'll
always die alone because it's not worth
becoming
close to others in the juju's world is
the real tragedy of his character
sukuna in contrast to this either
doesn't care
or has reached a point of no return
having become numb to the world around
him
and living purely for and relying only
on
himself same as with hisoka however as
modern neuroscience has found hedonism
and living out each and every one of
your desires
is anything but equal to being happy or
being fulfilled
instead this sort of hedonistic
lifestyle speaks for some sort of deep
trauma in the past
daniel kaneman an israeli psychologist
introduced the concept
of the experiencing versus the
remembering self
the experiencing self is the one that is
experiencing the emotional state in the
moment
like eating chocolate ice cream or you
know tormenting the teenager you're
stuck in
while the remembering self is the memory
of the experienced moments
looking back on it thus for instance
while relaxing at the beach in some sort
of resort is probably a lot more fun
while you're actually there
exploring the history of rome in the
heat of summer may suck while you're
there
but makes a way richer memory when
thinking back to it
and bringing this concept all the way
back to sukuna
when someone is only living purely
driven by the experiencing self
this usually means you prefer not to
engage too much with your past
and long-term consequences and so what
this tells us about the sadistic king of
curses
who used to be human after all is that
he most likely had a quite
tragic past that drove him into
abandoning his humanity
and so unlike mahito who akutami
actually described as being pure evil by
nature
i expect sukuna to have a much more
complex and rich background as to why he
became as cruel and lust-driven as he
has
and that will be one hell of a backstory
for sure
now coming back to our comparison while
gojo was pretty much
born with ridiculous strength and
perception and thus was always used to
having the upper hand in battle
sukuna despite his power is surprisingly
focused during all his battles no matter
if it's against gojo or megomi
he's always analyzing his opponent
trying to figure out exactly what's
going on
so he can counter as effectively and
efficiently as possible
as he himself mentions he appears to
have an extremely deep and detailed
understanding of what curses
cursed energy and true jujutsu really
are
[Music]
and all of that would make a lot of
sense i think if sukuna had to struggle
his way to the top
from basically rock bottom now one last
important parallel between gorge and
sukuna
in contrast to the individualism is
their approach to
others while they both prefer to rely on
their own power they
also both long to understand those
around them even if it is for different
reasons
in fact sukuna's one redeeming feature
for now at least
is that when people are strong he will
acknowledge them and actually
find them more interesting as we can for
example see with megumi but the takeaway
message here is is that
tsukuna is so focused on strength in
order to try and fill the emptiness
inside him
by satisfying his every desire
funnily enough he shares that trait not
only with gojo
but also with the main character itadori
yuji
he is the third person who also thinks
that power will help him live a good
life by trying to save as many people as
possible
and in regards to their relationship
sukuna not only bears similarities to
hisoka
but also unites element from stories
like naruto
bleach or attack on titan in other words
the trope of the vessel
[Music]
just like naruto and aaron itadori yuji
also serves as the container for a
source of immeasurable destructive power
that allows them to play way out of
their league however while aaron's titan
powers lack
any personality in themselves and kuruma
turns out to be a lonely
misunderstood and used creature that
doesn't actually want to get involved
with naruto or his life
sukuna is an actual evil person that
constantly talks to itadore and
actively tries to harm him and in that
sense i think that the closest and best
comparison that we can draw is actually
with
bleach and by that i mean the good part
of bleach and that is with
hichigo ichigo's star itself
[Music]
this dark self is an aspect of the self
that is presented as
an antagonist have you ever wondered for
example why tsukuna looks so much like
yuji
we never see the face he originally had
he always specifically takes itadori's
form
as we know while the part of tsukuna
inside itadori would perish if he were
to die
the parts of his soul in the remaining
fingers would nonetheless survive
so this specific sukuna that we have met
in a unique way seems to be tied to
itadori whenever itadori can't control
his darkest emotions like fear or anger
he starts to lose control over tsukuna
in other words
literally giving in to his own
hedonistic instincts
for example once itadori consciously
acknowledges his anger towards toto
he's finally able to deal with it in a
more healthy way
and so just like ichigo had to take
control over his shadow self to use his
powers
similarly it will be necessary for
itadori to take control over sukuna who
as we now know
only acknowledges strength in order to
actually profit from his powers and keep
him from hurting others
but most importantly himself because
interestingly enough
the only person sukuna is actually
fixated on is
not itadori whom he simply finds
irritating
but megumifushiguro what a transition
himself is such a fantastic character
that he deserves a video of his own
which will be the next one after this
luckily sukuna is not exactly interested
in fushigoro for his personality but of
course
for his abilities this connection
between the two has been hinted at
pretty much since their encounter during
the cursed womark
and just to get it out of the way of
course sukuna wants to use fushigoro for
his own purposes
either i would guess to regain his own
body or to take on gojo once he actually
has it back
[Music]
now these statements here were of course
triggers for both
megumi and the audience alike but for
different reasons
on the one hand sukuna's words show that
he has an interest in megomi and his
ability while giving the audience a more
in-depth idea of sokuna's tauntful
personality
on the other hand however they also
actually helped fushigoro to grow
something that sukuna keeps encouraging
in this moment here for example maegomi
prepares to use what gojo calls his
trump card an attack that is unconfirmed
in nature
but seemingly is the end-all be-all for
megumi
and funnily enough both him and gojo
have much more faith in his abilities
than he himself seems to have now
whatever it is that he sees in megumi
it seems to make it worth reviving
itadore and actually staying in his body
something he's not exactly enjoying
after all yuji being a one in a million
potential vessel
was a breaking point for sukuna to once
again feel human flesh
but we also know he doesn't want to stay
in yuji's body permanently
why not well after all yuji can control
his possession
and can become stronger as he absorbs
more fingers and should he die
the fingers within him would actually
die as well unlike with curses where the
fingers would just reappear where the
curse once was
as they cannot be destroyed by normal
means
and so i think it will be truly
fascinating to see how sukuna's plan
with for shigeru will play out
whether itadori will be able to get his
respect and if we will
ever get a true battle between him and
gojo
oh yeah before we go i wanted to shout
out arranial art who did the wonderful
intro animation for my sukuna song